learning learners much we can learn
something you know learning learners
learn learn
hello believes nation today I'm going to
give you some extra motivation for how
you can keep learning and as always as
people are talking is to say something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below of a
poster and other people can be inspired
as well enjoy you went to Harvard and
you're dropping out have you ever
thought how your life could be better
off if you had gotten your Harvard
degree well I I'm a weird dropout
because I take college courses all the
time I love learning company courses and
things so I love being a student and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you and they gave you
these nice grades that made you feel
smart so I feel it was unfortunate that
I didn't get to stay there but I don't
think I missed any knowledge because you
know whatever I needed to learn I would
I was still in a learning mode if you
could talk to your younger self knowing
what you know in those days when you
thought maybe it's not going to happen
what would you tell yourself very cool
I'd say
I'd play a cool and got learn as much as
you can because everything you learn
you're going to need you won't have
enough time to learn everything is an
education you should learn something and
each and everything around your planer
every single round should learn
something
well there's one thing it might be 20
things learn something for each and
every round and I've done that every run
that I've played I've come back home
I've critiqued my round
I've looked at it from a mental and
mechanical side what went wrong what
went right and apply it to the next day
of high society make a final decision so
I had
I think that for me I really like
learning technique you had a logical
like interference one thought of
creators one you know such tricks and no
one ranch on teaser trailer will look
cool I all want charge at me yes I
someone that kind of opinion with
healthy people rather that's how I learn
real learning learning youth creativity
creativity at least to be thinking
provides knowledge knowledge makes you
great
did you have a sense that that Coldplay
I reached the stage where you just like
you didn't want it to be that band like
you wanted something no we reached a
stage where we thought we can't get much
bigger so we have to try and get better
yeah
and it's that whole thing quality of
quality we thought well we we need to
practice a bit and improve them to
imbalance you know I was feeling bad
because I'm sure that some 16 year olds
or you know kids who say they like
Coldplay and then took some abuse for it
in the playground so I had a feeling but
18 months ago every would like to make
them proud
by by by uh you know trying to improve I
came up with a slogan and I told it to
my kids all the time I say there's no
losing only learning there's no failure
only opportunity and there's no problems
only solutions so to me what failure is
failure is the mother of all success if
it wasn't for Michael Jordan getting cut
from his ninth grade basketball team he
wouldn't became Michael Jordan you know
if there wasn't for I've seen an article
the other day where they were talking
about Oprah Winfrey and how she got
fired because she wasn't good for
television you know you got people like
Walt Disney who got fired if I'm not
mistaken from a newspaper saying he had
no imagination
to maintain a look at the saris handle
these are the same people that I got a
deal with tell me whether or not what's
not a hit record so what do you tell
them you tell them you know you know
that that all I can do is learn and come
back bigger better stronger because all
it's going to do is lead you in the
right direction see if you're always
winning and you don't really understand
what it is the wind you got to take
those losses you got to take those hits
there's got to be the valleys the peach
the UPS the downs in order for you to
when it does happen you go wow Eagle I
know this is what it's all about and not
only that it's never about making it
guys it's always about maintaining
that's the toughest part what one
quality you think you have that made you
gave you and allowed you pushed you to
achieve what you have I think my uh my
willingness to learn I'm pretty
relentless when it comes to that
you know I certainly knew everything
about growing up on the street and you
know what it took to survive on the
street corner Dorchester but uh this is
a whole new world to me
so you know just uh being able to take
advantage of the things that I've that
I've seen and you know the things that
I've been exposed to now with my career
is really good I continually learn from
my mistakes and other people's mistakes
the entrepreneurs think that hey to
create a billion dollar company 100
million dollar company or even million
dollar company have to be really smart
and sure brains is part of it
luck is a huge component but what I've
learned over the years is everyone no
matter how smart you are you're going to
fail many times you're going to make
mistakes just look at Mark Zuckerberg
Facebook work out his version of
snapchat that was a copycat
did not work out right so if there's
other areas in which Facebook failed but
Facebook overall as a company has been
great just because you're smart doesn't
mean you're always going to succeed with
everything you try your touch but every
time you do something you will learn new
things you'll make mistakes and if you
learn from these mistakes and avoid
making them over and over again you'll
actually increase your odds of
succeeding if M goes on and the best way
to do this is not just to learn from
your mistake
but it's also to learn something
mistakes of others Rockefeller Carnegie
all these people who are entrepreneurs
years ago in the 1800's 1900s they
themselves use business principles and
concepts that are still applicable in
today's world surely have the internet
but the same strategies and concepts
that they use are so applicable right so
learn from their mistakes learn will
work for them what didn't work then why
and bring that into what you're doing
today as you look back over your life if
it's just one thing that you could do
differently what would it be hmm that's
always always no question I get that a
question asked of us I'm not sure you
know because everything that happened in
my life produced me even the negative
even the things that I might have failed
in the things I've made mistakes with
they were fantastic classrooms for me
and I believe the best thing I'd like to
do is not to regret and try to change
what happened but to interpret it
properly maximize it and use it to serve
other people and that's what I want to
do with my path thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know whose message had the biggest
impact on you what was the clip that
left you wanting to make an immediate
impact and what are some of the
challenges that you have insane
motivated to keep learning leave that in
the comments below to the peers to find
out and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to [ __ ] awoke thank you so
much for that Instagram picture and for
picking up a copy of my book through one
word it really really really means a lot
to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is what you love
I'll cease it